le vélo électrique velits go prend place
sur le territoire notamment à la gare de
saint quentin en yvelines où une station
a été aménagé des futurs usagers qui
découvrent ces vélos bleu toutes
équipées avant d'arriver je pensais pas
trop parce que j'ai des enfants est
souvent le problème c est ce que je peux
mettre un enfant sur nos vélos pas
effectivement au moment de la
présentation de m'indiquer la
possibilité de bêtes en ciel où c'est
très bien pensé c'est très bien il est
assez facile il est assez simple voilà
il ya trois vitesses pour le mode
électrique et
donc très bien on peut le mettre en vélo
en fonction à la reine vélo complètement
normal et vélos électriques pour 40
euros par mois et une caution de 400
euros
un belgo étaient attribués pendant six
mois un usager pour le stationnement il
peut ramener son vélo chez lui dans une
station vélib ou le laisser dehors mais
risqué de se le faire voler si vous avez
un pavillon vous pouvez avoir la chance
de garder votre vélo facilement voir une
cave
mais quand vous êtes en collectif c'est
beaucoup plus compliqué et que dans les
collectifs déjà même les vélos
électriques se font parfois volé et
settat et c'est un frein du coup au
développement du vélo pour tout le monde
en attendant des locaux à vélo plus
sécurisé pour éviter tout risque de
casse et de vol les pistes cyclables
pourront être prises d'assaut par ces
nouveaux vélos électriques qui ne
demande qu'à rouler